The Nereid Under Ice has just documented life
under the Arctic Ice and it consists largely
of translucent worms and slimeballs.
And Hershey has unveiled the world’s first
public exhibit in 3D printing chocolate.
Vsauce! Kevin here - this is Mind Blow.
Scientists at Utrecht University have created
plastic eating fungus. Plastic is inserted
into cones of agar which the fungus then breaks
down and feeds on. The process only takes
several weeks which is significantly shorter
than the decades or centuries it can take
plastic to decompose on its own. And Livin
Studio is developing not only a prototype
for growing it but they’re also working
on creating different flavors so that humans
will want to then eat the plastic eating fungus.
GENiSYSS allows you to store your DNA on a
flash drive. Built with varying degrees of
encryption you to store a single drop of blood
on patented Whatman FTA material at room temperature.
And use the drive itself to store important
family information, photos, or video. So you
can fill one with emergency information about
your child to help EMT’s or create a DNA
family tree that tracks and could someday
prevent genetic disorders. Or clone yourself
later.
Whale poop may help regulate the Earth’s
climate. When whales surface they poop large
amounts of iron and nitrogen from deeper parts
of the ocean as part of what scientists call
poo-namis. These poo-namis cause a surge in
the growth of krill and plankton, which in
turn absorb large amounts of carbon. It’s
estimated that whale populations were once
responsible for removing tens of millions
of tons of carbon from the atmosphere every
year. The equivalent of annually negating
the carbon emissions from millions of cars.
A Japanese robotics company is developing
robotic action figures. Complete with motors,
sensors, speakers, and wifi connectivity,
the company's vision is that someday you might
be able to sit down at your desk and have
a Power Ranger action figure give you a high
five and read you your e-mails. And the concept is an evolution of Japanese Karakuri, mechanized
puppets.
The ninebot one is a motorized smart unicycle.
Fully electric it can reach speeds up to 12
MPH and can travel 18 miles before needing
to be recharged. You can customize it’s
outer shell, install headlights, training
wheels, and speakers, and use an app to alter
the color of its internal LEDs. It’s available
at select distributors in Europe, but not
currently in the United States, but there
is one in Canada.
An Amsterdam based designer has invented a
lamp is powered completely by living bioluminescent
bacteria. The lamp was built to sway back
and forth to mimic the movements of the ocean
which stimulates the bacteria into glowing.
While not yet commercially available, researchers
are working on finding ways to get the bacteria
to live longer so that someday we may be able
to use non-electric bio light.
Ring is a WiFi-enabled video doorbell. Utilizing
a 180 degree camera and a two-way speaker,
it allows you to use your phone or tablet
to see who is at the door and talk with them
without having to get up off the couch, or
even be at home. It also comes equipped with
motion tracking technology so you can set
the device to warn you if something unusual
is happening around your house.
Finally Sepios is an underwater robot inspired
by cuttle fish that can navigate thick tangles
of grass without getting stuck and observe
marine animals less intrusively.
Scientist: There is a very big need in technology
for vehicles which can move with higher agility.
With our system we’re recovering much of
the agility of these animals in their native
habitat which is many orders of magnitude
better than current technology.
I’m gonna leave you with the autonomous
walking of a hexapod snake monster. And as
always - thanks for watching!